donc benoît vous avez fait beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup d'interviews ces
dernières semaines vous êtes un petit
peu voilà vous avez peut-être un petit
peu marre donc on va faire une interview
sans intérêt
[Rires]
de fermer la voiture j'ai fermé la
voiture je les fais laver les dents le
garage ce que j'adore les bagnoles vous
le savez et je suis très gêné d'avoir
une vilaine couleurs pour la voiture
t'as pas vu ma personne je n'ai pas vu
sa perceuse non
cela a dû vous la posez vous préférez
les chiens les chats les chats j'adore
les chats
tu dors bien en ce moment je n'ai jamais
bien dormi
je dormirai bien mon repos finale
t'as pas vu ma mère cela me l'a fait
c'est cool non c'est très simple je
serai je suis impatient de voir si vous
allez faire cette interview avec anouk
aimée
alors nous qu'aimez vous avez ma
personne
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu